hello hello can you hear me yeah awesome
hi uh thanks for having me in Berlin I
just got here yesterday so I'm a little
jetlagged but I'm
here uh you can follow me at Twitter at
Gina and as he mentioned I'm a senior
product designer at Sal
Force um I'm also the design lead for
team SAS design uh we rebranded and
redesigned the SAS
website I'm going to start with one of
my favorite quotes uh it's it used to be
that designers made an object and walked
away today the emphasis my shift to
designing the entire life cycle and
that's by Paul safo um you know
throughout the the years I think in web
design people have moved away from
creating just pages and more towards
creating systems um and so that's um a
lot of what my work is involved with is
creating Design Systems um I'm actually
on the design team at souforce called
systems and we uh work on the style
guide uh you know maintain like all the
patterns and try to have consistency
because it's a really big company I'll
go into that a little bit more uh in a
bit another one of my favorite quotes is
by Nate foron which says a fractured
process makes for a fractured user
experience uh whether you're working on
design development copywriting product
management you know whatever your role
is we're all working towards a user
experience in the end and so it's really
important to have a really solid uh
process in
place so right now style guides are like
all the rage um pretty much every
conference has style guide talks now all
so thanks for letting me talk about them
um they've also come a really long way
um back in 2004 during my internship uh
Odin marketing design this was my first
time ever actually working on a style
guide and this was a PDF style guide and
it basically covered the brand
guidelines uh documented the CSS that I
was writing um and like the different
layouts and grids and I learned very
quickly that PDFs suck uh to maintain uh
for sale
guides fast forward to about 2007 uh I
was working at Apple and the Apple
online store and I started working on a
guide and I wanted to do it online
because I really did not want to do it
um on a you know in a PDF um I chose
WordPress which at the time I thought
was really smart
um uh I also I was so excited about
doing these online style guides I wrote
this article um for a list ofart called
writing an interface style guide and the
TLD drr of that article is um design you
document your design and brand standards
your friend in development standards and
to keep your sty guides current and
useful current and useful is the really
key part here and I realized that
WordPress was only slightly easier than
maintaining a PDF and nobody would
update it except me and so it became
pretty useless and it got discarded
unfortunately uh 2010 I was working at
engine yard and uh it's my first time
having to learn SAS they said if you're
going to write code you're going to
write SAS cuz we write SAS
um I was really uh hesitant at first
because I thought I didn't need SAS and
then I learned it wasn't that I needed
it that I wanted to use SS um it very
quickly became uh natural for me and I
can't imagine writing CSS without it it
was also my first time trying a living
style guide which is when you know you
put your style guide inside the
application um itself um this is what it
looked like really early in 2011 since
then it's evolved and um since I've left
the designers have kept it going which
I'm really happy to see um but the thing
that uh I realized when I was working on
this was um this was awesome SASS and
sty guides are super awesome
together
um I wrote about my process of uh
refactoring the CSS and uh doing a
living style guide on their um their
blog at engine yard so if you're
interested you can read that later it's
um in my my current workflow very
outdated but I think it still um holds
up in terms of like what that process
was like for me and uh the way I went uh
went about it back then the big thing I
learned is that you have to make
documentation a regular part of your
workflow and not something that you hold
off until the end cuz you're never
really going to do it if that's the way
you approach it um the other thing I
learned was you don't want to document
everything at once because you'll likely
give up I've done it many many times I
think I'm going to try to take
everything all in one go and uh then
ends up becoming this monolithic branch
and never gets merged and then it was
just a big waste of time instead you
want to document going forward as you
approach things if you're making
something new in your application that's
the time to document it if you're
revising something like refactoring uh
you know refactor it and then document
it
um when I was working at do uh we did a
living style guide similar to what uh I
mentioned before um but then we also
were working on the IOS and Android app
which does not live in a HTML and CSS
codebase because we were doing native um
whoa my next slide got messed up sorry
um this
is sorry ignore that that was supposed
to be a screenshot of the style guide I
I'll replace it when I upload my style
uh slides later um but the thing we did
in that style guide is uh we um
documented our elements and then at the
basic level and then branching those out
into components and then into layouts
and we also wanted to show each object
um every type of that object um all the
states of that object and the variations
a really good example of this is the uh
Android sty guide they'll show like all
the different like Focus States press
States disabled all that um and we
also did a responsive sandbox uh which
is basically a bunch of if frames that
we could work against and we used the
URL strings and we could just change
that out and all the iframes would
change and it was really handy for
getting a kind of a general idea of what
things would look like of course it's
not an exact representation of what's
going to be on your phone or your tablet
but it kind of gives you an
idea um during this process says I
learned that the visual changes that we
would approach for Native mobile were a
nightmare because um the way I was
handling it back then was I would design
it in Photoshop uh save out all my
screens and assets and Dropbox and then
post it up on a GitHub Wiki for that uh
project repository and that led to
really sad times for me because every
single change was just like that entire
workflow process over and over
again I'll come back to how uh we're
doing that now um at Salesforce in a
minute um in 2013 uh we launched the SAS
website which I'm still really excited
about and because I was writing um the
code for an OP sourced website um you
know there were a lot of things to
consider in this process um here's what
the site looks like if you haven't seen
it yet um the sty guide is live so you
can see it and it lives on the website
and similarly to how I mentioned before
uh we use some of the same tools it
turns so when we did the responsive uh
sandbox at do we actually handbuilt it
but it turns out um you can actually uh
use an open source version that was
built by Matt kirley that does all that
for you um so I recommend doing that so
when you open source a website that
means anybody can
contribute and that you know I wanted to
leave it up to like where if you wanted
to design something you could do that
too and so I was concerned about like
what happens if a color gets added the
style guide needs to be updated
too and so I started thinking about like
how to keep things maintainable and in
uh one Central source and so I was
looking at like how can a sty guide and
the SAS share like the same Source uh so
that you don't have to write the
variable and then write the HTML to
display the Swatch that would output
that
variable I'm sure we're all familiar
with the phrase don't repeat
yourself um so my Approach that I did
back then um you know this was before
SAS maps and all that stuff came out in
SAS um the site was built on middleman
which is a static site generator uh done
on Ruby so you can use like you know
haml SAS markdown um you know all sorts
of neat stuff that would normally come
in a ruby and rails app but it's just
you know simple static site
generator um because I was using
middleman um I was able to in the
there's a data folder where you can dump
in like Json or yaml files um and a less
known fact about uh SAS and Ruby is you
can actually change the extension to Erb
at the end of the scss and it'll still
compile assess but now you can pass Ruby
into it as well and so I stored uh my
names my colors in my ammo file and then
in my CSS I actually generated the
variables needed with the
values and then in the markup generated
all the swatches that would display
those and so we only had one central
place to store the colors and so every
time a new color gets added a new Swatch
just appears in the style guide um I
thought this was pretty cool and I was
really proud of it and I showed it to
Chris Epstein and he was like oh we
don't really want you generating your
variables like that and I was like well
give me a way to do this
better um but I still felt pretty proud
of it and it's it's still um it works
like this on the SAS site now but I'm
planning to go back and refactor it to
you know try to use sass Maps which have
come out um and see if I can do
something a little more sassy than uh
doing things in the Ruby and yaml and
Json and
whatnot
okay so now I work at Salesforce uh do
the company I mentioned before du was
actually part of Salesforce um and it
got Suns sited and then I moved over to
the Salesforce design
team and uh we're working on uh what
we're calling a living design system so
as I mentioned before style guides have
to remain current and useful the moment
they being current they're no longer
useful um and then they'll get discarded
so a lot of people have been working on
tools like automated sty guides that
will read through your CSS if you use
markdown in your comments they'll dis
display the documentation in the order
that your SAS compiles and um you know
show like what the component would look
like give a description um which is
pretty similar U this is this example
here's style Doo there's also KSS
there's a whole bunch of them out out
there now um our sale guide at
Salesforce is pretty similar to this
doco style so we write our markup in our
SAS um as a comet and it'll display in a
style guide but we actually take it
further and generate our components from
that as well you can check out our sty
guide at this app uh at this URL the sty
guide is actually what made me want to
join my team because I really thought
the style guide was beautiful and I
wanted to work on it so now I
do um but the thing I've learn at
Salesforce is design for Enterprise has
challenges really big challenges um we
have our responsive prototypes that we
work on internally and then separate
from that we have our responsive
production framework which is an
internal um framework called aura that
uh Salesforce has developed uh we also
you know are looking at iOS watch phone
tablet Android watch phone tablet
Windows phone and then we have all our
acquisitions and partners that want to
build within our uui framework as well
it's a lot to think
about and so um the big question is how
do we keep colors spacing sizes Etc
consistent across all these things um
how do we make the future design changes
easier across all these platforms and
all these things um and mind you all
those things I mentioned um we have many
many products too so like that's like
whole other layer on top of all this and
because a lot of different teams or
different products might be using
different platforms or different
Frameworks how do we keep our design
system agnostic um you know one team
might use SAS one might use less one
might be working natively and uh Android
um so how do we like work within all
these different things um there's you
know the phrase single source of truth
that's a phrase that we throw around a
lot in internally um how do we find the
single source of
Truth so when I started I presented um
you know what I did for the SAS website
and asked is there a way we can kind of
do something sort of like this but uh
not done in Ruby done in you know um we
we use node and so can we do this in
node instead and can we make it expand
all these different things and the
engineer I work with s actually built it
that day and I was so impressed and I
love working with him he's so smart so
uh we open source an mpm module called
Theo and it's basically a theme we call
it a token
generator um Theo is essentially um an
mpm module that lets you write all your
design in uh Json so like name and value
pairs like colors with their values uh
font sizes uh font faces like like what
whatever um is an like attribute um and
it'll then generate SAS it'll generate
less it'll generate stylus generates
Aura uh generates Json for iPhone it was
doing pis but it's been moved to iPhone
uh Json now and XML for Android and so
some examples of that would look like
like we would um write it like this uh
in the Json file and then it would
generate the SAS file NE necessary and
then all the different teams can consume
it you know whether they're using less
stylus or a and then of course the HTML
used for the style guide consumes that
as
well um on top of that it also tries to
be smart about the way these different
platforms uh take things so for example
color um we might do Hex for CSS rgba
for iOS or eight-digit hex for Androids
so it does that conversion process um
values uh for sizing can be different so
with CSS you might do pixels RS or M's
for iOS you might do points for Androids
you might do sp or dip um so it tries to
do the calculation for that as
well and then every time the various
teams build their apps they pull in the
design values uh via get and
npm and then everything's consistent
there's no more hard-coded values
there's no more asking like five or six
different teams hey can you bump that
font size up two more pixels um and you
know there's um it's a lot easier
because we do the work and then when
next time they pull it down they have it
we also have our assets stored in a
repository as svgs um like a GitHub
repository and we have another mpm
module that we open source called
blender which rasterizes the svgs as a
fallback and then our style guide
actually will just hook into this GitHub
repo and display all the assets
automatically and so we don't have to
update that manually as well as
well so a change in one place changes
everywhere and we get uh true
consistency um so Sanka the engineer I
was working with um he like he likes to
coin things and so he coined the living
uh actually I have that wrong it's not
style system it's living design system
and um one of the really great things
about this is um one of the engineers
that I've been working with that's uh
working on the aura U CSS framework told
me that it's the first time he's felt
that ux in engineering has been like
really truly collaborating together um
so that's really exciting and I'm really
excited to see how uh much further we
can take this forward and if you're
interested in reading more about it we
just uh posted a medium article about it
uh Sanka wrote it it's called living
design system and you know the slides
will be available later and so you can
get all the links um and so you can find
he he writes into a little bit more
depth of how we do
this um be regular and orderly in your
life so that you may be violent and
original in your work it's one of my
favorite quotes by Gustaf Flaubert um
and I like to think about that every
time I'm like working on Frameworks or
um you know anytime I'm doing like a new
project or if I'm revising uh past
projects um so we're really excited
about this and we're hoping to kind of
like see how other people use it and so
if you're interested um you know feel
free to Tinker with them uh submit a
pull requests or ask me questions um I
also want to see other companies um how
they do it I'm sure there's a lot of
different like Enterprise companies or
even like smaller companies that maybe
have a similar problem but are
approaching this in different different
ways I would love to hear about that
because um I think it's awesome that all
these tools are being generated and the
more you put out there like it's only
going to make the community better and
make us all better um so please like
share with me and uh you know like what
you're doing as well um you can follow
us on Twitter at Salesforce ux and our
dribble is Salesforce if you're
interested in more about team SAS design
and what we're doing there you can
follow us at Team SAS design uh as well
as on dribble I also host a local uh SAS
Meetup in San Francisco called the Mixon
if you're ever in San Francisco and you
want to give a talk uh let me know and
we can plan a whole meet up around you
coming um we don't always just have sass
speakers like it's just uh front and
focused um I'm also um super excited
about suszie which is a responsive
layout system that is agnostic to markup
it does the math for you but you can
have the classes or or you know markup
that you want it tries to stay out of
that which is really awesome and you can
follow me at Twitter dribble Instagram
and GitHub at Gina
thanks